four years after Russia set off an
international crisis when it seized
Crimea from Ukraine there are new
tensions in the region this morning the
Russian Navy fired on three Ukrainian
ships it said had entered its waters of
Crimea one even rammed a Ukrainian boat
now several Ukrainian sailors were
injured United Nations Security Council
will hold an emergency meeting to
discuss the confrontation Elizabeth
Palmer who's reported from Russia
extensively is following the
developments this morning from London
Elizabeth good morning good morning Nora
this clash took place in a busy shipping
channel that's used by both Russia and
Ukraine in a video was shot on board a
Russian Coast Guard vessel you can hear
an officer shouting orders to cut off
the smaller Ukrainian tugboat and then
he rams it now that tog along with two
small Ukrainian gunboats were
subsequently seized and docked in Russia
while the Russians showed more military
muscle even flying fighter jets along a
bridge that spans the channel the whole
area has been tense ever since the
Russian military invaded and then
annexed the Crimean Peninsula which was
until then a part of Ukraine back in
2014 the Ukrainians have called this
Russian action and aggression in Kiev
last night crowd protested outside the
Russian embassy
meanwhile the Russians are insisting
that those Ukrainian ships entered
Russian waters in violation of
international law as you might expect
the facts of the matter are still
unclear but the United States does
appear to be siding with Ukraine and we
know that because the Americans Special
Envoy on Ukraine Kurt Volker has tweeted
Russia rems Ukrainian vessel peacefully
traveling toward port and then accuses
Ukraine of provocation go mmm that's an
interesting question thank you very much
Elizabeth